[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
for the article ali mirage
and the sports writer alison kervin as
you might imagine the late football
result means we don't have all the front
pages yet
but here are a few of them the observer
understands that the labour leader sakir
stama is poised to unveil a post-brexit
economic policy
encouraging businesses and the public to
make sell and buy more in britain
scotland on sunday has seen a poll
suggesting a third of people north of
the border
are worried they won't be able to pay
essential bills over the next year
thanks to fiscal strain because of the
pandemic
and we're joined tonight by ali mirage
and alison
kervin hello to you both thank you very
much for joining us
post football both of you are able to
watch
from home and looking at the papers uh
all of them with a photograph of the
victorious england team
on their front pages let's start with
the observer a picture of
harry kane two goals uh from harry kane
allison back on form
yeah yeah very much so no it was a
peculiar game in some ways in the way
the goals happened at the beginning of
both halves but it was um it was great
and lovely to see harry kane being
right on top form again it's funny i was
previously the sports editor for the
mail on sunday and as i was watching it
all i could feel was the horror of what
it's like in the office
when you're doing these papers and the
pressure to get the pages away with
these late games
um so i really felt for them but they've
done well to get the big
pictures on the front and here we go uh
there's
the telegraph here um with
again a photograph of uh the england
team
celebrating jordan henderson there who
came
off the bench and scored his first
international
goal uh ally and um
as alison said it was straight in first
half
straight in second half england with a
definitive victory
yes and i think that the country that's
what the country expected and wanted
england were clearly favorites ahead of
this thai
and they delivered i mean ukraine had a
real tough match the other evening
which went into extra time they looked
pretty exhausted and battered after that
match
and all the expectation was on england
tonight obviously playing in rome
in the stadio olimpico 25 years since
they've made a semi-final in the euros
so a big moment and i think harry kane
was really on form he ended his route
in the germany match but you also had
inspired choices coming in um from
uh the the the the england manager
gareth southgate bringing in jordan
sancho
who i thought played and that's
absolutely brilliant uh game
on the right-hand side very very
impressive sterling again i mean the
financial markets would say that they've
been buying sterling for some
weeks because he's been so good and uh
you know he continued that run of form
and then you had luke shaw delivering as
well i thought it was an excellent team
performance and
i think gareth southgate has now sort of
cemented himself since he's become
an england manager over the last few
years as this sort of
very sensible stable not flashy
hard-working down-to-earth manager
who really has it's really made this
team very cohesive and he's got such a
depth of talent
to choose from i mean this was a match
where he brought on a number of
substitutes as you saw in the last 20-25
minutes
and jack greelish who's been playing
brilliantly in the last two
couple of matches wasn't even brought on
so this is a this is a squad with depth
with talent
and i really think that um you know
they've got a tough match ahead of them
uh you know denmark played well i mean
denmark in the denmark game today
i think i saw one of the best crosses
were the outside of a right foot i've
ever seen
i mean absolutely superb so they can't
get complacent but i think it was a
spirited performance
and really quite scintillating let's
have a look at the front
of the mirror now just coming
in to us as well and the mirror
semi-gods at the headline there
and allison haven't conceded so far this
tournament
the first team in euro history to start
their campaign with five
clean sheets can they continue
yeah well they've had a very good run
haven't they i think um
they will continue against denmark it
gets a bit more tricky after that when
they get to the final but then
by the time you're in a final it's uh
it's anyone's game i think the point
that um ali raised there was quite
interesting about the cohesion in the
team
and i think there are a couple of
aspects here that have really helped
them gareth is a very
cohesive manager and a lot of the
decisions he made having
jordan sancho on the pitch then deciding
to bring on bellingham so he had the two
players from dortmund together on the
pitch i thought was a really
a really clever idea and it's it's about
building up these little cohesive units
on the pitch that he does so well
um so yeah i think we should be um i
mean you is terrified of saying be
optimistic aren't you but
uh to the extent that we can be
optimistic we should be in this
tournament
and ali of course they were playing in
the stadio olimpico in rome with very
reduced
crowd england fans from the uk
not able to travel those who are already
abroad were able to go
it will be a very different atmosphere
at wembley on wednesday
i think it will be absolutely huge and
even though there were only a few
hundred fans
uh england fans in there who as you say
uh live in italy
uh they made a lot of noise and rightly
so i think it's going to be an
absolutely fabulous occasion
on wednesday the nation expects i also
think um i mean allison mentioned gareth
being a very
uh inclusive and cohesive sort of
manager but i also think one other thing
is
is worth mentioning i mean he has been
very focused
on really having a very strong
a team around him in in terms of
coaching staff as well
and if you even look at the fa's
technical advisory committee they've
brought in
outside experts so not footballing
people in
so sir dave brailsford who is obviously
known for his cycling prowess
um he's been brought in the head of
sanders military academy is also
advising on performance so southgate is
is a is a manager who's not scared to go
beyond
the usual footballing experts to try and
bring something different
uh to the team and i think it's paying
off i think his his player selection has
been absolutely exquisite i mean you
cannot fault him
i mean i think today people are asking
questions about
sancho uh essentia's inclusion and i
just thought it was absolutely
a stellar performance i mean sancho's uh
just signed with manchester united you
can see why
sterling against cincinnati and again
you know for someone like raheem
sterling
i mean his personal story is just so
moving i mean this is a this is a kid
who came to
the uk from jamaica when he was five
lost his father who was murdered
at two um dreamt of always playing at
wembley he lived in the shadow of that
stadium
and you know from queen's park rangers
uh to liverpool
um you know and now man city i mean he
is really on form
he's fought hard he silenced his critics
he's having an absolutely wonderful
tournament harry kane as well so i do
think that um we've had so many
being an england fan is not easy you
always have to live with disappointment
i mean football coming home
that iconic um tune sort of says it all
but i really do think
that this is is a really good team that
one of the best teams i've seen for
many years i don't want to jinx it but
i'm hopeful that they'll perform
on wednesday uh ali's optimistic um what
about you
alison let's just have a look at the
sunday people we came we saw
we conquered the headline there
how optimistic are you about england's
progress
going forwards i'm
optimistic about the semi-final
obviously we don't know who we'll meet
in the final yet but
that will be a more tricky game i mean
they did very well today
but they they did very well there's no
buts but
i think we have to there were there were
little gaps there whittled moments when
you thought oh if that was a better team
they'd have got through there
so it will be a tougher ask in the final
but
i think we should be commenting to
getting there and we're absolutely able
to beat anyone in the tournament so
um yeah i can't i think i think it calls
for optimism
and in terms of the style of play there
had been some questions about whether it
was a bit
boring but actually this defensive
approach gareth southgate we haven't yet
conceded
a single goal ally gareth southgate can
say
look it's working i'm giving you what
you want what
well to be honest with you i did think
some of the earlier matches particularly
the scotland game they were
pretty below par i thought they could
have done a lot better today by contrast
i thought they played very very good uh
football for the large spells of the
game i mean
their their ability to keep the ball to
keep possession for large chunks of the
game was
very very strong i mean they were
playing i mean you could see in the
during at least the first half of the of
the match
uh how many bodies the opposition had
behind the ball i mean they had a
backline of about five i mean very
difficult to penetrate that
and kane got through that um you know
very early on right at the start to get
you know
england away and i really thought that
their keeping possession was very good
the link up play was great
i mean the darting runs from sancho from
sterling
again going to the byline dragging back
was really very very good so
i'm actually um impressed uh with this
team i thought luke shaw again you
cannot fault the set piece uh play i
mean the corners
uh the headers that they made the the
free kick that was done i mean
they they did actually play very well i
do i do accept alison's point
that there were a couple of moments i
mean i know that um
jordan pickford um made a a little bit
of an error but
that's okay these things happen you've
got to bounce back quickly and keep your
head
in a pressurized situation so there are
little uh niggles that they need to work
on but i think overall
it was a very positive scintillating
performance i do think that they need to
be
a little bit careful they i don't think
they should think about the final right
now i think they should just think about
the next game and that's been
southgate's great skill
uh is just focus on the next game and
picking the right side
for the opposition in front of you at
that time and as i say i think denmark
you know they they had some moments of
absolute brilliance in their own game it
was a much scrappier game than the
performance that england had tonight
um but you know one game at a time and i
think the next game
is is the only thing that they should be
focusing on at the moment and not the
final
wise words we must all heed those and
not get too carried away at this stage
uh must be ali allison for now thank you
very much we're going to take a short
break but coming up
is the nhs safe enough that we can phase
out masks from july the 19th we'll be
discussing that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me ali mirage and
alison
kervin we're going to turn to other news
now yes there is some
uh the sunday telegraph uh has a story
about the pm
going to axe mask laws as he says the
nhs
is safe and that comes alison despite
warnings
from the british medical association to
the contrary today
yeah it seems an odd decision to be
honest i think uh
the on july the 19th obviously we'll
we're expecting everything to open up
again but
i'd have thought that masks would be
something that
would stay longer and i imagined we
might stay with masks for
for most of the rest of the year but so
it seems an obvious it seems like a
decision also to go against
medical advice when we're so close to uh
to the end of it all
um yeah that just seemed remarkable it
seems ali doesn't it that we're
shifting from legislation and
compulsory mask wearing to
individual responsibility there may be
some guidance potentially
that's right look the prime minister is
a libertarian this has gone on
longer than he would have liked i mean
he has made a number of missteps in its
uh
course of this pandemic you know locking
down late imposing
travel restrictions later than required
um
and making a number of other uh errors
along the way but the vaccination
program has been a great success
uh it looks like now the link between uh
infections
and hospitalizations and deaths if not
completely severed
is is is at least certainly um dampened
which is the reason why the prime
minister's coming up with this
sort of bullish stance now and july the
19th is now being regarded as
the new freedom day he's also backed up
by a new secretary
of state for health sadhu javed who's
making a much more
um sort of positive noises about opening
up very different to
the starts of matt hancock was taking so
i think all the mood music is certainly
uh right and i think he wants to move to
a position where people take more
personal responsibility
make those judgment calls for themselves
and we all know that we we've seen in
the past you know tourists from asia
back here back in the day you know
coming to london on their summer
holidays wearing moss and we always just
think they were a little bit odd
well now i think it'll become part of
the the norm that a lot of people will
continue to use boss
just because it'll make them feel more
safer particularly in confined spaces
like the underground and on trade
uh allison let's turn to the observer
now kirstalma
fresh from thursday's battle spend by
election
victory has a new economic plan to
unveil
this sounds i mean on the surface it
sounds excellent doesn't it the idea of
a plan to buy british and to invest in
british companies and develop british
produce
and return to sort of a very british
economy but
um it's a bit light on details this
article isn't it
it states the intention without perhaps
explaining with a great deal of depth
exactly how that will work
um i mean it's it's a a very
worthy plan but i can't quite see
there's not a lot of detail in here
about how it would really work
yeah ali it's about securing
high-skilled jobs for the future in the
green financial technology digital media
and film industries
in the uk far more public contracts to
be uh
awarded to british businesses how
bold a vision is this by kierstarma
given that
he is much criticized so far for people
not knowing
what he stands for well it's not a
vision uh yet
uh at this stage uh but what it is is a
step in the right direction and this is
coming from
let's remember a real pro-remainer uh in
kierstama who you know tried to
frustrate the uh passing of the uh
brexit withdrawal agreement on
multiple occasions so this is a move in
the right direction i think it shows a
element of maturity uh from starmer that
he's trying to pivot now
and trying to move on to more patriotic
ground which is important for him to win
back his
uh former voters uh in the red wall
which uh they lost most
recently in hartley pool and i also
think the labour party is a little bit
um
buoyed by the fact that they managed to
hold on to badly and spend
323 majority which is actually better
than it looked because they
held off a threat from george galloway
they've got about 8 000 votes
and the tories ended up fighting a not
particularly impressive campaign
in the dying stages of that by-election
so i do think that there are positive
things for starmer
at the moment i think he's won a
temporary reprieve so he can hold off
any
talk of a leadership election at least
for the summer come back strong
um in the in the autumn season for his
uh party conference speech
and i think this is certainly a
direction of travel but he needs to
paint a much
grander strategy and vision of where he
wants to take this this is just yet
another
sort of um a policy but it's not a
vision we need to know what his
grand vision for a uk in a post-brexit
world
is and i think we're still lacking that
at this stage we've lost allison for the
time being but ali
um let's turn to the observer again
and i'm not sure which edition of the
observer this one
is but it has the earlier edition
pre-euros had
emma radicano the 18 year old british
wild card
on its front pages and ali on any other
day
she could have expected to be splashed
across all of the front pages after her
performance at wimbledon today
well absolutely amazing uh performance i
mean she came out of absolutely nowhere
i don't i'm not sure anyone had heard of
emma radacani before but they certainly
know about her now and she's just sat at
her a-level and the thing that i loved
about her she came onto the court as
cool as cucumber
wearing the same air pods that i'm
wearing so clearly very cool
um and just took it all in her stride
uh i mean some of the shots she played
were just absolutely
outstanding i mean unbelievable uh
athleticism
and uh shot making ability that she's
displaying and in the aftermatch uh
press conference i mean only someone of
that age 18 years old not a care in the
world
taking it all in her stride saying you
know hey i thought you know
i would like to make it to week two so
why not why not me and good for her
she's trained by
andy murray's father-in-law uh nigel
says he seems to have done a very good
job with her
and um i think she's definitely one to
watch you know fingers crossed that she
can
continue this but i based on her shot
play today i think she's a really
exciting talent to watch for the future